[Music]
everyone's speculating about Dexter how
it's all going to end it really does
feel like things are closing in yeah for
him and I wanted any spoilers or
anything but it really does feel like
he's running out of time
he's gonna get caught how would you like
to see Dexter end oh no if he if he's
gonna die he should die funny you know
like he he represents himself in court
and he gets himself off and he's walking
down the courthouse steps and gets hit
by a bus they're probably not gonna go
for the people would hate that yeah yeah
we get really bad there's so many
possibilities I've actually thought it
would be interesting to do a final
season of 12 finales oh yeah that's a
great idea
yeah twelve so in each episode is a
different implausible way that Dexter
dies exactly he's like well it looks
like he gets in a balloon and then boom
it blows up quicksand episode was a test
any chance do you get people who are
fans begging for a cameo like I've
watched almost every episode I think I'm
almost caught up and you know it's just
a natural thing like could I get a cameo
oh but I don't know how I would be a
cameo in that show right well I mean I
guess the obvious choice for a cameo
role is somebody who's a victim
Knight just because it's a one-off right
right maybe but it would be I think it
would take people out of it if maybe if
you were like a birthday clown and you
wore you wore makeup yeah yeah but you
were really committed birthday clown and
you had to make up tattooed on your face
yeah went away SEPA so at the end we
taped down on the table we have to
actually get the tattoos we would just
no no I'm gonna get the tattoos mark I'm
gonna get the tattoos before I even know
that this episode is being written yeah
well that's yeah that's the way to show
people your commitment you know I went
on the Showtime website and they were
talking about Dexter's character and
they said Dexter has a great sense of
humor and I thought that's kind of
interesting is I'm not sure just extra
have a great sense of humor he has like
kind of a sense of irony but voiceover
things like invite people to laughs um I
don't think he's like ready to do a
tight tent at The Improv or anything you
know he's a stand-up comic know kind of
funny no no but he's but he's got
this guy's leg the other day and you
ever noticed when they're killing a guy
and trying to dispose the body
crickets yeah I find something very
annoying about Dexter which is each
whatever he wants he doesn't seem to
work out right he doesn't seem to get
enough sleep and yet he's always in top
condition yeah what the hell is going on
there I mean every other scene is you
like biting into a giant you know he's
got like the extreme stress management
workout it just jacks up his metabolism
because you've got so much stress in his
life he climbs walls those three windows
and it takes a lot you don't there's a
lot of stuff you don't see on the show
too like it takes a lot of calories to
turn yourself into smoke and
invisibility yeah a lot yeah those seems
right right and even if we do he's
invisible
yeah so basically saying is that serial
killing is a viable weight loss
technique you heard it there America no
I'm saying the power of turning yourself
into smoke and or invisibility as a
weight loss technique
well yes stress management stress
management but I can't advocate it no
you can't have it at you yeah why would
you that would be insane no no I want to
keep people guessing I don't think it's
a primer on serial-killing the show I
mean it's not that looks fun it's very
stressful this guy's life
that is not how I watch it I'm watching
I'm telling you I watch it like it's a
way to go yeah in the know and then tie
them down and talk to him for a while I
like yeah I'm taking notes tell them a
secret and then yeah you're gonna start
noticing members of my band just
disappearing one by one look they don't
care they're so beaten down whatever
we've got a good run do what no